we just want to bring you the latest  pictures uh coming  to us now with a ursula von der lion uh  the first pictures  of her officially signing off that uh  trade deal  the brexit trade deal uh we'll remember  that  it was a claim to much fanfare by the  prime minister boris johnson on  christmas eve as a relief uh  many fearing that there would be no deal  which would have  many negative consequences but uh the  prime minister hailing it a victory that  he managed to deliver and  sign a trade deal with the european  union  and that is esther vonderlein signing  off the  brexit trade deal in brussels um  these documents we believe will be flown  to the uk  for the british government to sign off  their part of the deal but there will be  a vote in parliament today as we know  on that brexit trade deal of course  we'll keep you updated on the progress  of that